he will face ross stripling who gets
ready for his sixth star of the season
record a season high nine strikeouts in
his previous starts that's one off of
his career high that he set with the
dodgers it was also in just five innings
in that no decision against the braves
that was last thursday tk the five-game
hit streak at 239 with four homers
that one's rocketed and battling the sun
out there is guriel and jerry you
mentioned this last night left field
there's a lot of sunshine out there yeah
some of the reports i've heard of the
fact that you know they changed the
start time for games an hour back
because they were having problems seeing
the baseball and
a little send up alex for dougal he's in
right field tonight
and he'll turn on this and smoke this
pits to right that ball's out of here
bouncing around on top of that tin roof
for a two-run homer
bradugo just smoked it
alex didn't waste any time right there
jumping on the first pitch that he saw
two-nothing red sox just like that jd
martinez has an almond and a dozen games
pitching there's a drive hit the right
center field this is crushed up into the
wind this one is long gone
home run over the picnic area for jd
martinez an opposite field shot
his first home run in a dozen games and
it's three-nothing red sox as they go
back to back
verdugo and martinez in its
three-nothing red sox just like that and
the red sox have two men in scoring
positions if they get the bullpen busy
five straight hits to open the game for
the red sox after last night's
frustrations where they were shut out so
it brings up vasquez
and that's up the middle backhanded by
simeon he'll go to first base in time as
a red sox score again bogart's hand to
touch home deborah's down to third four
nothing boston 207 four home runs for
bobby
gonna line that shot that's into the
alley that's going to keep on bouncing
up against the wall another run is in
rafael devers scores and it'll be two
bases in an rbi for bobby d
to make it five to nothing
garrett richards looking for win number
four yeah picked up the win last time
out against the oakland athletics five
hits in that game in six innings no runs
bow drove in a run with a double in the
fourth inning last night it was his
60-second career extra base hit
and he's got a hit right here this could
be an extra base hit simeon's headed for
third moves making the turn he's going
to end up in second with another extra
base hit and now simeon is caught in
between third and
he is out
marcus simeon
came around third with a full head of
steam i'm not sure if rivera put up a
stop sign or not but he had visions of
scoring
so here's maddie guerrero
and he hits a fly ball to the center
it's going to be over hernandez's head
and off the wall beau had to go back and
now they're waving him home and there's
the throw to second and guerrero is safe
blue jays are on the board
and sox really swinging the sticks
against ross strippling in the first and
then it started with this man
[ __ ] hernandez lashing a base hit pulled
it to left
high deep drive left field racing back
urial track wall and see you later
he turned that win around red sox have
already hit three home runs
in the first couple of innings on
stripler his fifth home run is 11th rbi
at 6-1 red sox
he walked in the first inning and he has
now reached base in 23 of his last 24
games he drives this one to rye this
one's up in the wind it's gonna be
over the glove of verdugo
syrian is headed for second another
extra base hit and he continues to swing
the red hat back
that's his eighth double of the season
and the blue jays are determined to get
back in this game there's beau buchet he
doubled his first timer oh two swing and
a miss he struck him out that's the best
curveball that richards has thrown
tonight well it certainly isn't pitchers
i don't think there's any question about
that i mean they just amp up and throw
as hard as they can so now two down
after the lead off double
and here is tayo scar hernandez the
pitch
swinging a hard shot to short bogarts
has it on one hop he plays it throws to
first in time
blue jays can't take advantage of a lead
off double they leave simian stranded
stripling has retired six in a row since
the home run by kiki hernandez leading
off the second
[Applause]
there's a breaking ball for a strikeout
that's the third strikeout as that
curveball gets damaged
seven in a row now the wind
blew his hat off and put it on the field
jonathan davis the center fielder making
sure it got there that guy needs to get
back in the gym i tell you yeah
letting himself go
again out runners at first and second
now
vasquez has hit two ground balls they'd
love to get another off his back ground
ball biggio has another chance second
for one back to first double play of the
year
does not cost the blue jays
kent thornton gets the double play
it's the fourth walk issued by
garrett richards and he's encouraging
the blue jays that they can get back in
this game
there's a swing in a chopper devers goes
airborne got him at second on the first
and the red sox turn another double play
[Music]
garrett has gotten three double plays
tonight
and a good job pitching around a few
walks technically four of them in the
game for him
six hits against gary richards a one
high fly ball into center field
hernandez under [ __ ]
makes the catch
and a souvenir for somebody 6-1 boston
[Applause]
garrett richards still out there
and his run of really fine starts
continues
and that's it oh made a terrific pitch
94 miles an hour to strike out biggio
pretty nasty down on the outside corner
down low
jonathan davis with a walk and a tapper
to the third baseman on a windy evening
here at dunedin and that's in there for
strike three frozen
no trigger there for davis back-to-back
caves
you wonder whether that will do it for
richards now nearing a hundred pitches
thrown well his night is over an
outstanding performance again by garrett
richards and he's making that routine
gives way to garrett whitlock does
inherit a runner at first base
man on with two down
we're gonna drive to left field this is
trouble this is going to be
that two-run home run for marcus simeon
his 10th home run of the season
he's been on base all four times he's
come to the point is he ever hot right
now wherever they throw the ball he's
hitting it and he's hitting it hard
christian vasquez quiet tonight over
three pitch swing there's a drive to
left field hammered over toward the gap
way back and this ball is gone
vasquez who had a home run taken away by
the win last night it's a line drive
home run over the fence and left center
his third homer is 17th rbi and that
makes it 7-3 boston bottom of the ninth
now 7-3 red sox lead blue jays are down
for their last out
there's a shout out to center field on
the move kiki hernandez to make the
catch and that's a win
for alex cora
and the red sox a 7-3 final score